drug maker moderna has announced its
coven 19 vaccine
is extremely effective the news comes as
cases continue to rise in nearly every
state
there have been a million new cases
across the u.s now in less than one week
and many hospitals right now are on the
brink of getting overwhelmed carter
evans reports from hard hit salt lake
city
covid cases are pushing utah's hospitals
to the brink and things are almost
certainly going to get worse according
to dr brandon webb
we do know what's coming we're seeing so
many cases
day over day that unless definitive
steps are taken to interrupt the
transmission cycle
exceeding capacity is a mathematical
inevitability
grim scenes continue to unfold in el
paso texas
where county inmates were loading bodies
into mobile morgue
trucks over the weekend the county judge
there says using inmate labor indicates
the city's level of staff shortages
more than 200 people have died in that
city from covet
in the last month with cases and
hospitalization smashing records at
least
27 states have imposed new coronavirus
restrictions on businesses
and gatherings in the last two weeks on
sunday in michigan which saw at least
496 guests from kovitt last week
the governor announced a three-week
freeze on indoor dining
and in-person learning for high school
and college students
if we don't take aggressive action right
now
we could soon see 1 000
deaths per week here in michigan but
without more targeted restrictions
hospital systems nationwide could be
just
weeks away from their breaking point
according to infectious disease expert
michael osterhome
my worst fear is what we saw happen in
in other countries
where people were dying on the streets
people literally were dying in the
waiting room of emergency rooms after
spending 10 hours
just waiting to be seen that's going to
start happening and we will see
the breadth and the depth of this
tragedy but there is new hope in the
fight against covet 19. this morning
pharmaceutical company moderna announced
its new vaccine is 94.5 percent
effective in phase 3 trials
last week pfizer said its similar
version of a covet 19 vaccine
was more than 90 percent effective
carter evans cbs news
salt lake city the government says both
the pfizer and madonna vaccines will be
free
both do require two doses health experts
say there will likely be doses by the
end of this year for some at high risk
they do expect widespread distribution
by spring of 2021 so we'll of course
follow that